[Music]  that's Celine Dion leading an epic  sing-along as cher slays at the 2017  Billboard Music Awards ET was on hand  backstage to catch the sweet moment both  singers had a big night at Sunday's  award ceremony in Vegas Cher accepting  the icon award I wanted to do what I do  since I was four years old and and I've  been doing it for 53 years and Queen  Celine earning a standing ovation for  her emotional performance honoring the  20th anniversary of Titanic  [Applause]  [Music]  I think I have the big winner tonight  for me is the crowd like that's all  everybody's talking about I thought that  it was a drop in my sound and they said  no it's because the people you had the  biggest choir in the whole wide world  you you were you were they were singing  with all of you that's included it was a  retouch  [Music]